ADDY OSMANI: Hi there.
My name is Addy Osmani.
I'm an engineer on
the Yeoman team.
And today we're going to walk
through creating a new web
application using Yeoman, a
workflow comprised of tools
for improving your productivity
and speed during
development.
Yeoman is comprised of
three main tools--
Yo for application, Bower for
front-end package management,
and Grunt for building
your projects.
Let's dive right in to
creating a new to do
application from scratch.
To get Yeoman installed,
you'll need to
use Node and NPM.
Make sure you have recent
versions of both available so
that everything works
correctly.
So we're just going to run NPM
install g, yo, and allow it to
go install its dependencies.
And we're now going to install
an AngularJS Yeoman generator
for scaffolding out
a new Angular app.
Now, you only need to do this
once, so NPM install g
generator angular.
Fantastic.
Now, we can go run yo angular
to begin scaffolding a new
application.
This will ask us a number of
questions, such as do you want
to include Twitter Bootstrap?
I'm going to say yes.
It gives us options about
whether we want to use Compass
and a few other angular
resources.
What this process is now doing
is fetching any dependencies
needed for our AngularJS
workflow and scaffolding out
any files required
for application.
Next, I'm going to preview
what this looks like.
So I'm going to use
Grunt server.
And this is now firing up a
local server for me to preview
me application.
And there we go.
Because this project is using
Live Reload, I can actually
make changes to my sources, and
without me having to do
anything else, it'll refresh
my browser for me, so I get
this real time view of what's
going on inside my app.
Now, I'm going to go to my
angular controller that was
scaffolded out.
And what I'm doing right
now is I'm creating a
new array of todos--
so item one, item two,
and item three.
And these are some simple
todo items that'll be
reflected in my app.
I'm now going to go
back to main.html.
And we're going to define a
template for these todos.
My todos is going to be the
title of this page.
And I'm going to start
defining my
template, so new paragraph.
And I'm going to use NG repeat,
which is an angular
directive for allowing me to
basically repeat something for
different items in
a collection.
So I've got repeat, todo, and
todo, so for each todo in my
todos array.
And I'm now going to just
declare a new input field.
And I'm using NG model which
represents a new angular model
with two way binding.
As you can see, it's now
reflecting the todos array
that we defined earlier
inside my page.
Let's now add the ability to
create some new todo items.
And I'm going to define
a new form for this.
So let's go down.
Let's create a brand new form.
And I don't need the
action on it.
But what I am going to do is
that NG submit, which is
another angular interactive.
And I'm going to say, call
add todo whenever
this form is submitted.
What we're now going to do
is just add some divs for
styling, some div wrappers
for styling, add
some classes on that.
And next, I'm going to add an
input field referencing our
todo model.
So there we go.
And NG model equals todo.
Let's give it some constraints
for the number of characters.
And we should also probably add
a button just to say add
or something like that, so that
when you've typed in some
text into your input field, we
can just click on Add to add a
new todo item.
And there we go.
Awesome.
Let's now head back
to main.js.
As you can see, there's a
preview of our application
displaying the new field
and the new button.
We're going to head
back to main.js.
And here we're going
to add in that todo
function to our scope.
So there we go-- add
todo function.
And this is basically going to
push new todo items to the
todo array every single time
that you create a new todo
item from the UI.
There we go--
perfect.
So let's quickly
test this out.
So let's say buy some
more milk and add--
there we go.
It's working.
Learn AngularJS suite--
awesome.
So that all works great.
Next, let's look at the ability
to remove todo items.
So I'm going to go and head
back to my main.html file.
And we're going to add a button
to our template, which
is basically an x.
And that's going to appear
next to each to do item,
allowing you to remove it.
So here we've added another
directive, NG click.
And it's basically referencing
remove todo,
passing through a reference.
And, as you can see, the x now
appears next to each item.
And we're going to head back
to main.js and define our
remove todo function
within our scope.
So scope.removetodo
equals function.
And we're going to use the
splice function which lets us
remove old elements from an
array using an index.
And there we.
Index one--
perfect.
So let's try this out.
Buy some more milk.
We've added it and removed it.
And as you can see, this
all works great.
So how about next we make
our todo items sortable?
So let's refresh the page.
We're going to use the Bower
package manager for this.
So what we want to do is use
AngularUI, which is a
companion to the AngularJS
project for UI components.
So first I'm going to list what
packages I have locally
installed using Bower Lists.
And as you can see, we
have a few of them
pre-installed for us.
And now want to check to see
if AngularUI is actually
available via Bower.
So I'm just going to type in,
Bower search AngularUI.
And as we can see, it's
already up there.
So I can now just run Bower
install, save, AngularUI.
And there it's gone
and installed it.
So all we need to do now is just
add some references to
the AngularUI stylesheet and
script within our index file.
So components AngularUI
build, AngularUI.css.
And let's add a reference
to our script as well.
So script src equals components,
Angular UI build,
angularUI.js--
fantastic.
And the last two dependencies we
need are jQuery and jQuery
UI, which I'm going to just wire
up using some references
to copies that are
hosted on a CDN.
So there we go.
We've got jQuery 1.9.1,
jQuery UI 1.10.2.
And I've now saved them
in my index file.
So now that we have AngularUI
installed, we can add a
reference to it in
our app.js file.
So let's head on
over to app.js.
And inside our angular module,
we've just defined a new array
referencing UI.
So we're going back to
our todos template.
And I'm adding a div wrapper
around our todos with the UI
sortable property on there.
And refreshing--
and let's try this out.
Awesome.
So as you can see now,
I'm able to sort my
different todo items.
And that's working
on all new items.
Let's add in a new item
and see if it works
on that one as well.
So buy some unicorns--
perfect.
As you can see, that's
working great.
Now we can sort our todos,
and that works fantastic.
So one thing you might notice
is that when we refresh the
page, any todo items that we've
created automatically
get reset, because they aren't
being persisted.
Let's change that, so
they get saved to
local storage instead.
This time we're going to install
the angular local
storage package--
so Bower install.
There we go.
And now we're just going
to wire it up
inside our index file.
So src equals components,
angular local storage, angular
local storage.js.
There we go.
Now, going back to app.js, I
need to add a reference to
local storage modules.
So inside the same array as
earlier, local storage module.
And there we go.
And inside our main.js file we
need to add a local reference
to local storage module.
So we're going to call it local
store service, just so
we can access it inside
our controller.
I'm going to comment out the
todos that I had earlier, the
ones that I hard coded in.
And we're going to add some
code that's, first of all,
going to read any existing todo
items from local storage.
Under the todo name space, we're
going to then split them
up based on a new line character
so that we can get
back anything want
into our array.
So todosInStore.split
based on new line.
And then we're just going to
register a watch expression,
so that we can keep our todo
items name space updated with
a joined version of our todos.
So watch, function, and
localStorageService.add todos,
scope.todos.join.
New line.
Save and test that out.
So now I'm going to create
some new todo items.
So learn, AngularJS, add buy
some unicorns, add learn to
skateboard.
And now let's refresh
the page.
They're still there.
Let's open up the Chrome dev
tools just to check if these
are being stored.
So as you can see, they're
actually being persisted to
local storage, which
is fantastic.
So now we have an application
that works.
The next thing we want
to do is write some
unit tests for it.
So let's comment out the code
that we just added and reset
back to the static ones that we
had earlier just to make it
easier to test for a moment.
So I've got my original
todos array.
And now I'm going to head on
over to my Karma unit tests
that were scaffolded out for
me when I ran yo angular.
So I'm heading to main.js, and
here's some boilerplate code
for my unit tests.
And we already have an assertion
here that says it
should expect a list of awesome
things in the scope.
Now, awesome things, if you
remember, is that array we
initially had, which just
defined a few items to display
on the [? lo lo ?]
boilerplate page.
Let's replace it with todos, as
we've now got a todos array
inside our scope.
And as you can see, all I can
here is change this to check
on the todo items that I
find inside my scope.
And I want to check that the
length is equal to three.
Let's save that.
Let's run Grunt test.
What this is now going to do
is go and fire off Karma,
which is going to run
our unit test.
We've got a spec runner
running in the
background for us now.
And that's really it.
You can check to make sure
that your unit tests are
running correctly.
Now, the next thing you'll
probably want to do is build a
production ready version of your
application linking to
your code, minifying and
concatentating your assets,
and handling any abstractions
you might be using, like
CoffeeScript, and creating an
optimized build that you can
push to production.
So we can do this just by
running the Grunt command.
And there we go.
It's ready.
Now, the final thing you might
want to be able to do is
deploy your application.
You can customize your Grunt
project to deploy to pretty
much anywhere, whether it
be Google App Engine
or something else.
But in this case, we're going
to deploy to Heroku.
Now, I'm going to use another
Yeoman generator to save me
some time here.
So I'm going to go back to the
command line, and I'm going to
run NPM install generator
Heroku.
You normally have to go through
a number of steps to
push to Heroku, including
using get
to handle this process.
But using this generator
save us a lot of time.
As you can see, it's going and
it's installing any of the
dependencies that it needs.
It should be done
in just a sec.
I can now just clear my screen
and run yo heroku.
Now, this is just going to
generate me some configuration
that I can copy to my Grunt file
for my Heroku deployment.
So it's going to ask
me a question.
Do I want a separate Git
repository in dist?
I'm going to say yes.
There we go.
There's our configuration.
Now, I just need to go and copy
paste this into my Grunt
file under the copy task.
So there we go--
copying that over, back
into my text editor.
Perfect.
And now I just push my dist
directory, which contains the
production version of my
application to Heroku.
And so let's CD into dist.
And I can run Heroku
Apps Create.
And now I just need to push it
to Heroku-- so get subtree
prefix dist, Heroku master.
Perfect, and now it's done.
Now here's a version of my
application that I pushed to
Heroku earlier.
And that's it.
I created a new application.
I was able to use Yeoman to
basically scaffold it out,
build it, test it, and I pushed
it to Heroku, so I can
easily share it with
other people.
Now, if you like what you saw
with Grunt there are actually
hundreds of Grunt tasks
available to help you achieve
lots of common development tasks
at build time, including
compiling your CoffeeScript,
or using something like
grunt-contrib-connect to hook
up your application to some
middleware, like
Express or PHP.
If you like what you saw with
Bower, there's actually a
growing number of easily
installable packages on the
Bower registry.
And the number of open source
projects supporting it and
using it are growing weekly.
Bower is great for handling
dependency management for you.
So if you want to easily update
your dependencies, you
just run Bower Update, and
it does it for you.
And Yeoman has a growing
number of generators
available on NPM.
We actually have over 50
available at the moment.
And they're not just useful for
kickstarting off brand new
applications.
Yeoman can be used to scaffold
out little bits of
applications, as well.
So if you wanted to create a new
Angular view or directive,
you could actually just use the
same Angular scaffold that
I showed you earlier to create
that at the command line.
We've got generators available
for Backbone, Angular, Ember,
and a growing number of
different frameworks.
So feel free to check out NPM if
you'd like to get some more
of those generators installed.
And that's it.
If you'd like to learn more
about Yeoman, please feel free
to check us out at yeoman.io.
Until next time, thanks,
and goodbye.